so here is a video of NYU students New
York University students I used to hang
down by this area all the time removing
posters featuring missing Israelis so a
group of people put up posters at NYU
and it's it's all over New York City of
missing Israelis right people whose
families have been butchered and killed
and here are these these tolerant and
nobody's illegal and peaceful and
diverse uh Hamas supporters uh pulling
those posters
down like think of the gall of this
again imagine you're just sort of you
don't if you don't care about any of
this uh and again I as I've said
repeatedly like I care about this I care
about this because I do care about
Israel but actually it's mostly because
I care about America and I care about
freedom and these battles these are no
longer local geopolitical battles these
are these are the battles of our time
right they they are and they're
worldwide right why did the Hamas leader
call for an international day of jihad
uh on Friday right an international
Jihad not just like an extra Jihad on
the Jews like it was an international
one okay um I want to throw a close-up
of those posters so these are the
posters there in the New York City
subway so they're not calling for death
they're not calling for murder or any
saying anything about a response or
anything else they're just saying these
people have been kidnapped we would like
these people back these young people
these children these women they've K
they've literally kidnapped grandmothers
who are holocost survivors it's just
it's just absolutely insane and everyone
should get to know those two gals uh
that we just showed you the picture of
because you might you know I assume
they're NYU students they probably want
jobs one day and you might we' have to
think if you were hiring by the way we
are hiring a an extra uh editor right
now the Ruben report is continuing to
grow uh can you make sure we don't hire
those two chicks all right we're putting
that down um but it continues at the
universities and it's not just the
students again the students are the
pawns these kids don't know what they're
protesting they don't know what they're
saying they have been fed lies forever
and they're just pawns you guys are just
being used and they don't you think
Hamas gives a about the purple-haired
douchebag who's out on the streets of
Dearborn Michigan you idiots anyway it's
not just the students that's the point
of all of this it is coming from The
Faculty it is coming from the
administration uh here is an image of
University of Michigan Professor his
name is Eric Gordon we should get to
know this guy I'm sure he'd have a
lovely life in Hamas uh he has a little
gay face I would say this guy's probably
gay he's got he's got gay face to me
that strikes me as as gay face um here
he is tearing down posters of kidnapped
Israelis some of them US citizens being
held in
Gaza